Rancho obi-wan is the world's largest
private collection of Star Wars
memorabilia and for the last year or so
we've been operating as a non-profit
been doing lots of tours and I've been
having a lot of fun the collection
consists of everything from original
crops to fan made items original art you
name it there is very little that has
not been made worldwide at some point
for Star Wars and if it hasn't been then
some fans somewhere has probably made it
this bike was built by my friend and
former colleague Pete vilmer it's based
on a Skywalker Ranch bicycle but tricked
out for the Empire Strikes bike or back
or something like that so we've got
lightsaber headlights and taillights
we've got a Darth Vader horn we've got a
little a dad here just in case they
won't get out of your way you can carry
your lunch back here and this is a ship
from Oh Empire Strikes Back
it's what everybody escaped on from the
planet hot we have inventoried probably
about 95 thousand items so far we think
that 95,000 is probably one third of the
total collection so we're estimating
somewhere around 300 thousand separate
pieces
we give charities the chance to auction
off tours of Rancho obi-wan and then
we're starting to do tours for school
groups and we ask the teacher in advance
okay what would you like to stress on
the tour they'd like to stress Star Wars
and real world science Star Wars as a
method of finding your career there's
lots of different ways that we can go
and I'll select the things that we show
and we talked about based on what the
teacher is interested in
I think Rancho obi-wan just reawakens a
lot of people into the joy of Star Wars
and the fund that they first experienced
whether the first movie they saw was
Star Wars or The Phantom Menace on the
big screen and I think Star Wars has
become a multi-generational saga both in
the movie and among fans there was an ad
slogan that the first toy company Kenner
came up with very soon after they
started selling Star Wars toys it was
Star Wars is forever and you know what
it's true